I just got back from the hardware store where I picked up some replacement blades for my utility knife.
Because overtime, these things get dull and pretty rusty.
But, as I took the old blade out and took a good look at it,
I had a revelation on what kind of project we could do today.
Can you see what I see?
[BATMAN TRANSITION MUSIC]
That's right guys! In this video, we are making bat blades out of utility razors.
So, I went ahead and took the liberty of making up a nice little bat blade template.
Were going to use these to transfer an image to the blades that will make it a bit easier for cutting out the steel.
Now, razor blades like these are designed for hardness.
Which, means that the steel has a very high carbon content.
That makes them extremely hard, but, extremely brittle.
When you take your razor blades out of the package, you're going to notice that they're very oily.
And permanent marker isn't going to stick to that.
So, we want to start off by cleaning these off with paper towel and maybe even some rubbing alcohol, to prepare the surface for ink.
One grease free blade, ready to go.
Now, these templates are kind of reverse templates.
So, you'll want to take something like an Exacto knife and we're going to cut out the shape and we want to leave a negative
because, we're actually going to paint the picture onto the razor blade itself.
So,when your piece is cut out, it should just pop right out of the paper and that will leave you a negative that you can position over top of one of your razor blades.
Once you got a template that you're happy with, go ahead and put the paper facing down on the table.
Then, take your blade and put it down over top of the back
and when it's lined up exactly how you want it, go ahead and take a piece of tape,
could be Scotch tape, masking tape, whatever you want,
and just carefully put it over top of the razor blade and press in down to the paper.
That will secure it in place
and that will make it very easy to spray paint or use something like a permanent marker to transfer the image onto the blade itself.
Go ahead and throw your template onto the table and grab something like a permanent marker and go ahead and color it in.
Now you'll want to give that about 10 to 15 seconds to dry and you should be able to remove the tape and extract your blade.
So, we got a cool little bat image transferred to our razor blade,
but, it's important to know that you're not going to be able to cut these things out with a hack saw blade.
You're not going to be able to cut them with metal files.
To cut out shapes in high carbon steel, we're going to need to use grinding wheels and rotatory tools.
Alright boys! Glasses on for safety. Let's get down to business.
Alright guys! There you have it!
It's not pretty. But, it's going to get the job done.
So, now we can use our diamond tip dremel tool to to clean up all of those edges to make it look sharp and really crisp.
So, update guys! The diamond tip bits do not work.
Do not get these.
I've gone through 3 of these, including one that I just got from Home Depot for $8.00 and it burned out in about 30 seconds.
Not to mention, that I ended up breaking like three of my blades, so I'm on my fourth one now and I did find I did find something that's a lot better
and it's these mini cut off wheels for the dremel tool.
These things by themselves will cut out your entire shape if you go slowly and carefully enough.
So, you see, guys, just using the mini cut off wheel, you can actually cut out the entire blade.
This, by far, works better that any of the other tools that I was using.
They're very durable, they're very cheap, and they do a much better job than these other bits.
The only thing that you have to be careful of, is that when you're grinding your bat blade, you grind with the edge of the wheel.
You don't want to grind with the flat surface or you might end up tearing your disc apart like that.
So, this is awesome, guys! Our bat blades are looking really cool.
They look awesome in sliver, but, if you want to make them look a little more authentic, grab yourself some black spray paint like this.
This is the kind that dries in about 10 to 15 minutes.
Just poke one of the tips of your bat blade into a cardboard base, give it a shot of spray paint from both angles and let it set.
This paint should take just a couple of minutes to dry. So, while we're waiting, let me tell you about the Wounded Warrior Project.
With the holiday season approaching, I wanted to share some information about a charity I recently learned about that helps veterans.
The Wounded Warrior Project and its supporters believe that warriors already paid their dues on the battlefield.
Their vision is to foster the most successful, well adjusted generation of wounded service members in our nations history.
The Wounded Warrior Project also empowers warriors to live life on their own terms as well as mentor fellow warriors to embody The Wounded Warrior Project logo of one warrior carrying another.
The mission of The Wounded Warrior Project is to honor and empower wounded warriors.
So, big thanks to The Wounded Warrior Project for sponsoring this video and you can click the link in the description to learn more.
Alright, so, update. Our paint is dry.
These bat blades are looking awesome and at this point, all we have to do is to take a little bit of sand paper, a sanding sponge, or even a belt sander
and use it to remove the paint from the tips these blades just to make it look a bit nicer and at this point, we're ready to go.
Just for fun, I printed out out a little target so we could do a little throwing practice with our bat blades.
I got to make sure I don't miss because I don't want it to stick into the sheet rock.
Fail.
I think it's all in the wrist. You got to get that little snap. Maybe.
Oh! Bangerang!
Check that out!
Well, we just got his collar.
It's a pretty solid shot.
I would like to see that the other direction though.
Hee-Yah!
Ohh! Right in the knee cap.
Oh! Right in the knee cap again!
Oh! Dang! See that's what I was afraid of.
The one time I miss, it goes into the wall.
Boom! There it is.
That's what I'm talking about right there.
So, there you have it guys.
That's how you take blades from your utility knife and turn them into batterangs.
How cool is that?
But, remember that these things are not toys.
They are very dangerous, they are very sharp, they are razor blades.
So, use safety and use caution if you try making them yourself.
Thanks for joining me for this project today. I'll be looking for you in the next one. Talk to you then.
[GRANT LAUGHS]
That is epic.